un sistema de salud al borde del colapso
las existencias de sangre se agotan
según los bancos de sangre que
permanecen activos que dan existencias
apenas para dos días más lo que hace más
difícil atender a los heridos que deja
el conflicto interno que padece este
país desde mediados de abril el personal
médico teme que sigan aumentando las
víctimas por falta de atención oportuna
tras el cierre del hospital de ondurmand
El único que está funcionando es el del
nau todos los días Tenemos que recibir
decenas de enfermos y heridos debido a
que algunos hospitales en la capital no
tienen capacidad quirúrgica porque sus
condiciones son limitadas desde que
iniciaron los combates de los 89
hospitales que tiene Sudán ya se han
cerrado 59 en los que todavía funcionan
el personal médico resulta insuficiente
tampoco se cuenta con todos los
especialistas que se requiere la
situación sigue deteriorándose y se hace
insoportable por lo que viene el
hospital cada 10 o 15 minutos mueren
pacientes por escasez de medicamentos
solo puedo rezar para que desaparezcan
todas las enfermedades que todos los
pacientes se recuperen lo antes posible
y que el país restaure la seguridad y la
estabilidad la crisis del sector salud
en sudanes angustiosa los medicamentos
también escasean y en muchos centros de
salud son frecuentes los cortes en el
suministro de energía eléctrica y de
agua potable